We have all witnessed the beauty of meteors, but have you ever thought about it?
What happens when an asteroid enters the orbit of the Earth?
Can we detect it in advance? And more importantly, can we stop it? I believe
I have an answer, you know, the asteroid hits the earth.
It’s a very serious thing, when I was in the second grade, Ms. McGonigal told us
Ancient dinosaurs disappear because their brains are small
May be like...
My old boss. But even she knows that this is a very convincing theory.
As a result, it turns out that in my lifetime, people discovered craters.
In Hick Sulubo, Mexico. This crater is very big, how big is it?
An asteroid hits the Earth as large (or some impactor hits the Earth)
When you hit the earth, put a lot of things into the sky of the earth, its original diameter
More than the Earth itself, so the earth is surrounded by hot rocks for a while
It cooked everything, except for some animals that lived in the cave
That is our ancestors, and finally evolved into us. Some serious accidents you may remember Valentine's Day
year 2013
Russia's Chelyabinsk air burst.
If you are an asteroid, you are moving at 10 km/s or 20 km/s.
And you hit the earth's atmosphere, the atmosphere is as hard as concrete
You can't have other methods, it can only explode in the air.
Therefore, these asteroids are serious, most of them
They are all very small. If you are less than 10 meters in diameter, you will burn when you hit the Earth's atmosphere.
Blue stripes, green stripes
And white stripes, then humans will make a wish to you
(I don't know how effective these wishes are, but people are doing this)
anyway,
If the volume of the asteroid starts to be larger, the diameter is up to 25 meters.
45 meters, then you will have a meteor crater in Arizona.
Huge thing
This is like a city killer or a county killer.
Then, when they reach 100 to 140 meters in diameter, you will encounter a national killer.
When they are bigger, they will be the killers of the whole continent; when they become bigger again
You will
There is the demise of the entire different ancient species.
So, if we find out that an asteroid is coming to us, how do we find it?
"How do we find the asteroid that is moving toward us?" This is a very good question.
You can use a telescope, some skilled people can use the camera to aim at the sky and
Looking for fast moving objects
Some objects that traverse the Earth's orbit. But we may not be able to find out
100,000 of these things:
The killers of these counties, the city's killers and the country's killers.
So what we want to do is to build a spaceship called "Sentinel"
As we said: "It's like looking for (dark black) charcoal briquettes in the dark."
These things are hard to find. They are insignificant compared to the vast space
But infrared light and heat will bounce off them, so what do you do -
When you are a satellite, you are a measuring spaceship
You will turn your back to the sun, then
Looking outward from the orbit of Venus, try to find
All these asteroids. Then when you find one, what do you do? Will you scream in a circle?
Do not! Do not! Do not! We should deviate from the track, just
A little bit, just a little bit is enough. Asteroids may advance at 10 km/s
We want to change its speed
About 2 mm / sec.
So 10 kilometers, that is 10 times 1000 meters, that is 10,000 meters,
One millimeter, which is one thousandth of a meter,
So if you take one thousandth, you will be one thousand to ten thousand
That is 100,000. You want to change the speed of one tenth of a million
This is actually not very much
But if you are an asteroid that is rushing to Earth
And from 10,000 tons to 100,000 tons
This does require a lot of force to change the speed of one-tenth of a million.
Ok, then
How do we do it? The easiest way
Is using a rocket, a big rocket, launched there.
And hit it. Except because it is in space, it just happens (silence) like this happens
Ok, this will change its speed a little bit. I will inform everyone now,
In case it is not just a stone? If it is a pile of rocks
Loosely combined by the original gravity?
So if you hit them, they will only spread out, and you only get a rain of rocks
This result is not good. So what about this?
We will use a huge spaceship, this huge spaceship will go there
Close to the asteroid
Because it is close to it, then because of the mutual attraction
You - the gravitation between the asteroid and me - the spaceship
Will open a little asteroid
Just a very small distance, or maybe it’s the same from the other side.
This may work, but there are still problems
We need a lot of fuel to supply for a few days,
Weeks, months and years.
If it stops running, you can't go out and fix it.
So how about this -- laser?
One group
Solar powered laser
Bombard the surface of an asteroid
Years and months
ZAP ZAP ZAP will make some asteroids, some rocks are evaporated
Will produce a spurt, or generate momentum when something is ejected
Just like rocket fuel, just like standing on a skateboard and trying
Then a bowling ball...
Doing so will
The asteroid changes its speed. And you can put some lasers that can emit
Spacecraft is sent to heaven
If one of the spacecraft fails, you can use the other one. And you can
Place them at different angles if the asteroid
The shape is irregular (like this)
You can shoot it on a smooth surface
Then when there is a pit or depression, you turn it off
Wait until the asteroid goes to the right side and reopen it. look,
Just because it is unlikely, it doesn't mean it's not important
You know, this can happen only once every few thousand years, but if it happens
My watch (representative: when I live)
It will say like the children: "It's bad." Well, we don’t want this to happen, we want
Avoid this situation.
Asteroids are a serious problem, but they are also exciting
(Spacecraft noise) It is (silent) except that we are in space.
Do you have a problem that needs to be solved? Then remember to subscribe to asapscience
Follow us on Twitter and Facebook, this is what all kids are doing.
If it is an asteroid, it may not be a problem in the burning (extremely solved), but
An impactful problem, even
Is an ablation problem